Dính phát triển chung Quốc bị lừa bán sáng viên mà tôi phá hội lựa tôi cách lừa đảo.
Theo sinh dinh bao ngày mừng tám tháng buộc, sau khi được cạnh sóc thái Lan dài kiểu đưa về bằng cốc,
vương tinh kể lại sự việc.
Cuối năm ngoái, anh đọc được tinh tuyển dụt, quy định lý thái tìm hiểu công việc.
Ngay mục bà tháng buộc, diễn phía nhập cạnh nước này,
vây ra của anh hạn tới ngày mừng bà tháng ba, để chỉ lưu chú là phách sản ở đảo vực kệ.
Từ sân bay, vương tinh được người của công tý muối giới việc làm đưa đến trái nát,
tình ở biển chung thái Lan, tiếp đó tới tình tắc, năm ở biển giới thái Lan, miền mà.
Sau đó, người thân và bản gái không thể đến lạc với anh.
Dính phíanh kể sau khi qua sông, anh mới biết đã vào điều phẩm miền mà,
biển những người cầm bu khí app lên xa đưa đến một cân nhá.
Tại đây có ít nhất năm 2019, buông tình còn được sĩnh qua một cân phòng nhiều người ở các nước khác.
Theo anh nếu ta, tất cả người ở đây điều bị bụt cạo chật đồ.
Trong bà ngày bị nút, tôi phá hội lượng vương tinh kỹ năng lừa đảo qua tinh nhắn văn bà.
Nhưng chúng chưa kịt phẩm gián vông tinh kinh thức lừa gạt qua gọi dịch.
Anh nói, đó là những ngày khủ khí, tôi phố cùng khoảng sự,
lo lắng miền khủth hiện nào được xảy thoát khỏi đây.
Cảy sát thái Lan kết lận theo đổi xa văn đầu, văn tinh là nạn nhân của tối phạm buồn người.
Một khọt hai ngày tới, giến viên có thể bị chúng khúc.